in the beginning the great frif made the  world he determined that there would be  a meeting of all the animals owns a hunt  and slay the rabbits hazel something  will come to this place we can leave now  and we can be destroyed with it  good heavens I mean good gracious I mean  all the world will be your enemy when  they catch  but first they must capture  my name is Wu blur general won't word  but dick  I think he's incredible I think you've  given us a home you have fought so hard  to earn your freedom but now  you must fight to keep him he will find  the outsiders but when you do we will  destroy their water work that need no  trace of them on this huh  my body's may like broken that what  connects us is unbreakable  you  [Music]  you